good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have a special ability to create
something amazing that can change the
planet so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to be
more efficient rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best
[Music]
the reason why you have not become
successful the reason why you are not
like a locomotive the reason why you're
not having success in your life it's
because every single day you've got an
excuse I need you to do me a favor I
made my last excuse yesterday my last
reason I came up with my last reason
yesterday I why I can't do what I'm
supposed to do and so I need you to do
me a huge favor all your excuses all
your good reasons everything every
everything that's keeping you from doing
what you're supposed to do I need you to
put it behind you and say yesterday was
the last day for that foolishness
yesterday was the last day to say I'm
having the money to do this I'll have
enough money to go to school I'll have
enough money to get a computer I don't
have what it takes I'm not smart enough
right I don't write well enough
I don't sing well enough that's why I
didn't do my CD I didn't write my book
cuz I'm not on that level listen to you
better hear what I'm saying
yesterday was the last baby I want to
hear an excuse it's over with
everything you people have told me I
didn't have the technology I'd have the
right contacts I didn't have the time I
didn't have money everything you've told
me I didn't have enough Supreme Court
justices those are resources and so
you're telling me I fail because I
didn't have the resources and I'm here
to tell you what you already know
resources are never the problem it's a
lack of resourcefulness is why you
failed because the ultimate resources
are emotional states if you're creative
enough can you find the answer yes or no
if you're determined enough can you find
the breakthrough yes or no if you're
passionate loving enough can you get
someone to help you yes or no if there's
no way that you're committed can you
find the money even if you don't have it
yes or no
so I said creativity decisiveness
passion honesty sincerity love these are
the ultimate human resources and when
you engage these resource you can get
any other resource on earth and I said
so you told me all the resources you're
missing and you hypnotized yourself into
believing that you don't have what you
want because you don't have the
resources when the most successful
people in history had no resources but
they were incredibly resourceful so they
got the resources resourcefulness is the
ultimate resource and if you don't have
what you want stop telling yourself the
story because you don't have the money
all the time
that's [ __ ] it's because you haven't
committed yourself where you would burn
your boats if you want to take the fun
Island burn your boats and you will take
the island because people when they're
gonna either die or succeed tend to
succeed but most of us give ourselves a
way out and that's why we don't have
what we want
other than hard work what advice would
you give to better yourself both in life
and in your career field focus focus is
super underrated like if you commit all
that you are and all of your energy to
one thing you'll okay this like this
tires out this is I took this from a
book called I don't know what it's
called but it goes like this alright you
can do ten things to like the first
degree like this right here and that's
how well you'll do all ten things or you
can do one thing
to the tenth degree right there and look
how much better you do that so when it
comes to focus to put all of your energy
into one thing is to do that one thing
really well to the best of your
abilities to take it all the way and to
scatter yourself means you're never
actually accomplishing anything you're
just sort of chipping away at a bunch of
nothingness and this is true for work
this is true for like dating versus
committing yourself to one person
friendship everything like really
focusing and investing yourself into
something you're passionate about will
always yield better results then
scattering yourself around and spreading
yourself thin make a damn schedule and
stick to it okay so what's the rule with
the schedule it's not a bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong is say well I don't like to have
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
I should I have to do this then I have
to do this then I have to do this you
know and then I just go play video games
because who wants to do all these things
that I have to do it's like wrong set
the damn schedule up so that you have
the day you want that's the trick it's
like okay I've got tomorrow if I was
gonna set it up so it was the best
possible day I could have practically
speaking what would it look like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that then at the beginning of the
day right that's a stupid day if you
have a bunch of those in a row you just
dig you know you dig yourself a hole and
then you bury yourself in it's like
sorry that's just not a good strategy
it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20% of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are but even that you can you
can ask yourself okay well I've got
these responsibilities I have to
schedule the damn things in what's the
right ratio of responsibility to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you got
work tomorrow okay so I want you to work
tomorrow and you might say okay well
what are you gonna do for me that makes
it likely that I'll work for you well
you could ask yourself that you know
maybe you do an
of responsibility and then you play a
video game for 15 minutes I don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life and and that's how
you make the schedule it's like and then
you look at the day and you think well
if I had that day that'd be good great
you know and you you're useless and
horrible so you'll probably only hit it
with about 70% accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero right and if you
hit it even with 50% accuracy another
rule is well aim for 51% the next week
or 50 and a half percent for God's sake
or because you're gonna hit that
position where things start to loopback
positively and spiral you upward the
next piece of technology that will help
you create exponential productivity in
your work life so you truly impact the
world around you is choose your peer
group really really well there's a lot
of excellent science coming out and a
lot of excellent research coming out
that says the number one way to improve
your behavior is to surround yourself
with a peer group or social circle of
people who are also playing at the level
you want to be playing at so if you want
to be a high performer in terms of your
pride productivity populate your life
with high performers now here's the
science behind it in the brain we have
something called the mirror neuron
system of the brain and it dates back to
thousands of years ago when we were
living on the savanna and this mirror
neuron system allowed us to model the
behavior of the dominant people in the
tribe so if someone figured out a tool
or figured out fire or a better way to
survive
subconsciously this system in the brain
allowed us to model the behavior and I
think this is pretty fascinating
information now here we are in the
modern world and what happens
subconsciously we are modeling the
behavior of the people we spend most of
our time with and so if you are around
victims you will start behaving like a
victim if your estelle around people who
are mediocre performers you will
subconsciously start behaving like them
if you around people who
who are not a players who do not produce
very much you will subconsciously
because if the mirror neuron system in
the brain start performing like them why
else is it important to surround
yourself with a pure set or social orbit
of a player's emotional contagion and
that's a scientific phenomenon that
simply says we pick up on the emotions
of the people that are around us and so
if you are around a social circle of
people who are inspired people who want
to do great work people who want to be
ultra productive people who want to be
innovative people who are relentlessly
optimizing their work their thinking
their creativity just being around them
will allow you to adopt their energy and
their ways of being to become the most
productive person you know baby
turn off your phone right now I don't
want to do it I don't want to do it
either I don't blame you right but I've
noticed that if I turn my phone off and
this is what I'm reaching for like every
single day I turn it off a one-hour
totally like sometimes I mean nature I
turn it off right and it just helps like
it just your mind is clearer like is it
healthy to have all of these
notifications every single second I
don't think so right one born with a
mobile phone like checking updates and
stuff right so for me what's helped me
is to get back into a more organic flow
and then I just start getting more
downloads because once again you connect
to nature you get the organic download
and that's really the secret of great
productivity sometimes take a break from
your phone and it was hard to do you can
have to leave it some time let it go let
it let it go thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know what did you
think of this video what was a rule that
most applies to you that you're going to
immediately implement somehow into your
life or your business please let me know
I'd love to hear from you leave it down
in the comments below I also want to
give a quick shredder to Oscar and dare
mo Oscar thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word for
doing the fun in your view on your
and for all the support in promoting the
book I really appreciate it and I'm so
glad that you enjoyed the read today's
book book report is the one word by Evan
Carmichael so thank you guys again for
watching I hope you have an amazing day
I believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon